a crisis for Public Health a crisis for
the economy the government's economic
forecaster today spelling out an
apocalyptic scenario two million
unemployed and the economy shrinking
more than in the financial crisis these
are tough times and there will be more
to come as I've said before we can't
protect every business and every
household I'm wondering whether the
hardship might have to continue after
this if we have such a high level of
debt that the UK economy is going to
look slightly different than it was only
a few months ago obviously we'll have to
take stock of public finances in the
economy and make the right decisions at
that point and I've talked before about
when doing whatever we need to to right
the ship at that point but what I would
say is that we remain very committed to
the agenda that we set out before which
was about leveling up and spreading
opportunity around this country and
indeed I believe that can still be a
critical part of how we get back to
normal was that a first hint of the need
for a new economic manifesto once this
is all over today the office budget
responsibility sketched out a scenario
of a twelve point eight percent fall in
UK economic output this year that's a
bigger one year fall than in the
financial crisis world war two all World
War one or the Spanish Influenza the
deepest slump in fact since 1709 the
good news is the obr thinks the economy
could bounce back with a whopping
seventeen point nine percent growth next
year the bad news is that the
International Monetary Fund thinks
actually we will be left worse off
permanently the pandemic may not recede
in the second half of this year leading
to longer containment period worsening
financial conditions and further
breakdowns in global supply chains in
such cases global GDP will fall even
further the ground level is clear that
life for most businesses has changed
forever even fortunate ones like this
one a catering business which has
pivoted into making standalone sinks for
the NHS are still struggling if it was
not for this product we would
we wouldn't be working at the moment I
would have had to furlough all of the
staff I've got a lot of concerns about
the future market watching cash flow on
a daily basis and this is all because of
the uncertainty in the future we're
currently estimating that our sales will
be down at about 45 percent of what we
saw in January and February there are
millions of stories like this businesses
whose income has dropped sometimes to
zero businesses which may not survive
another few months of lockdown
tightening downing streets dilemma in
effect the government is caught between
two sets of horrific statistics both of
which have come into sharper focus on
the one hand you've got mortality
numbers the highest number of weekly
deaths from any cause in the past decade
and a half at least but the more the
government tries to push down on those
through the lockdown the more it runs
into the other horrific statistics
potentially the worst year for the
economy in a century maybe three
centuries according to the Office of
Budget Responsibility so as it considers
whether to extend the lockdown it's
pretty clear there are no easy decisions
here
yet those numbers do not lie there's no
doubt now this is a major mortality
crisis no doubt the response is causing
an economic crisis the only doubt now is
about how many more lives are damaged by
both Eddie Conway Sky News